[Music]
my name is Michael Sullivan and I have a
story I think you're gonna want to hear
I knew his father he'll do the program
is called oil-for-food the UN would
manage the sale of Iraqi oil and use the
profits to provide humanitarian relief
to alleviate the hardship I will do
anything I can to help your child it
sickens me to have to stand there and
listen to your nice Justin cutter
Central Intelligence we think oil for
food is being gained for private gain
possibly with help from the inside which
is where you are a wrecker spying for
you just keep your eyes and ears open
that's all there are some after service
fees I'm pretty sure they're kickbacks I
took this job because I want to help
people come on kid you wanted a career
in diplomacy while you're missing your
golden moment your predecessor he was
murdered you need to be very very
careful you know it's very dangerous for
you to be in this godforsaken desert um
escorted well consider this a courtesy
get in the car
for as long as I can remember I wanted
to make a difference we peek through
this my dear this is how it works Moscow
Beijing Saddam has funds mafia greed new
sorry do you'll make it they can save
the world
trust me
[Music]
you